so i have two numbers here the top
number i have one two three tens and i
have one two three four five ones three
tens five ones or thirty five
the second number here i have two tens
one two and i have one two three four
five six seven ones two tens and seven
ones now what i want to do is i want to
add all of these numbers to or i want to
add these two numbers together i want to
add 35 plus the 27 or another way of
thinking about it i want to add i want
to add all of these blocks together i
want to add all of these blocks together
so let's start let's start in the ones
place right over here
so i have five ones here i have seven
ones here so if i add five ones to seven
ones how many ones am i going to get i'm
going to get 12 ones i'm going to get 1
5 6
7 8
9 10
11 and 12.
now you might notice a problem here
because if i take 5 plus 7 i can't write
the number 12 in just the ones place i
just need to have one digit i can't have
two digits there so what can we do
well what we could do is take 10 of
these ones and group them into a 10 and
put that and put them into the tens
place what am i talking about
well what we could do is we could take 1
9 and 10. so we could take these 10
right over here and group them together
into one of these
bars so let's do that so let's group
them together into one of these bars and
then stick that bar in the tens place so
all i'm doing here all i am doing here
is
give me one second let's see all right
whenever i so all i'm doing is i'm
taking these 10 right over here
and i am regrouping them into the tens
place sometimes this is called carrying
so instead of writing 10 ones i'm going
to write it as 110.
so instead of writing it as 10 ones i'm
going to write it as 110. so what does
that do for us
well now i only have two ones in the
ones place
i only have two ones in the ones place
but now i have one more ten in the tens
place
and i have one more ten in the tens
place sometimes people call this
carrying because you see five plus seven
is twelve you write the two in the ones
place and you write the one in the tens
place twelve is one
two let me make it very clear
five
plus seven
is equal to
is equal to 12. and all we did is we
wrote the one here we wrote that in the
tens place we wrote it up here so that's
why it kind of looks like you are
carrying it you're putting it at a
higher place but you're just writing
this in the tens place and up here was
just an easy place to do it but remember
all we did all we did there is we said
look we have 5 we have 7 that would be
12. we can't write a 12 in the ones
place so let's take 10 of those 12 and
regroup them as a 10 and then we have
the 2 left over here but an easy way to
think about it is 5 plus 7 is 12 1 2
and now we can add the tens place we
have 1 10 plus three tens plus two tens
well what's that going to be well that's
going to be six tens one plus three plus
two is six so let's do that so we have
whoops wow that was
that's not what i wanted to do
let me
that was kind of all right
we have
we have one
two
we have
three
and
we have four
and we have my computer slowing down
five and then we have
and then we have six
six tens
and so what is that
what does that leave us with
one plus three plus two tens is going to
be six tens 35 plus 27 is 62 35 plus 27
is six tens and two ones sixty-two